I've also forgotten what Japan is like
with tourists in this country now
because most of the time I've been here
it's been during covert rules so I'm
like because I've never really lived
here when the country was really open I
don't really count the first like three
months that we were here because that
was just like an extended holiday you
know what I mean
that's what it felt like well I'd say
it's quite nice that there's no foreign
tourism
I was going to say when the country's
open now we're going to be complaining
about the fact that I've started getting
recognized a lot more uh in certain
areas and I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah this is
what it's probably gonna be like but
legit I got to the point where it's like
if I saw a white Post in the distance
I'm like is that someone I know
so it's like wait how did you get in
here it's like I swear go to the one
with like every white person in Japan
just knew each other it's like oh [ __ ] I
went to akihabra not too long ago
because I need to pick up a bunch of
stuff for a video yeah and I got
recognized like four or five times
one of the most common places yeah and I
was like yeah yeah gone like full force
here What's it gonna be like exactly if
you want to get spotted the most I just
say asakusa yeah my experience it was a
weird experience as a foreigner going
into the American Embassy in Japan
everyone just thought it was American
and every time I went in like the
visitor the immigration then they're
like no no this way this way and I was
like no no I'm I'm not I'm not American
I'm like what are you doing yeah yeah
four separate occasions I had like
people think I was American and like try
to tell me to go to the the American
citizen thing because I was like the
only white dude to there and I was like
oh this is okay this is weird and I was
like I wonder if God got this
I definitely didn't get that they're
like oh he's where you belong that's all
right
trying to get a green card okay I see
you just married an American as well
okay okay yeah that was weird and I was
like oh racial profile
oh that was weird though that was really
bizarre okay for the American Embassy
yeah I've never been into an embassy
before that wasn't the Japan one in the
UK yeah in Japan oh really no why would
I why would I have gone why don't you
just like British Empire times it's like
a really pleasure estate it's probably
the best Embassy in Japan
it was like even walking up apartment
blocks up to the thing that had [ __ ]
tons of security and I was like whoa
yeah you walk in they're like oh
reservation for Barry Chopsticks
that's weird it's weird it was very
intimidating going into Iraq American
Embassy is terrifying yeah scary getting
into man
that was terrifying
why not because they're like I went
through this whole thing and then
because you guys got yours on the spot
right no they just said they was
approved I didn't get that yeah that and
so that that was terrifying well you
didn't get approved on the spot no I got
refused
they were like you're already American
why would you need it obviously
just come back with your actual passport
all right so you go to this like there's
like three inspections right and yeah
this feels pointless yeah when you hear
the word interview I thought we were
going to sit down with the dude yeah but
then I may realize oh I guess the amount
of people that are coming doesn't make
yeah yeah yeah yeah why you want to
laugh
nothing mate
he's building up to something I know so
you go into this embassy it's terrifying
you're like all right everyone looks
depressed and miserable uh yes so we go
through it go through the first two
things I I changed my appointment date
so then that caused so many problems
already right and they were like the
date is wrong on the file like I changed
the appointment date and they were like
it's not what it says on our system like
can you please look again and they
looked again and it was yeah and then
they were like
typing vigorously for 10 minutes so I'm
like
all right everyone else is way quicker
than this yeah yeah I wait she goes
around back with my like my passport and
stuff I'm like what the [ __ ] is
happening it comes back she's like all
right go on the next thing go on the
next thing finally go to the interview
yeah and the interview is not what you
imagine you know sit down at a desk like
I thought was gonna happen yeah the
glass screen and someone it's like
you're going to a bank yeah yeah
literally a bank teller yeah like kind
of thing and they just ask you questions
and I don't know what they asked you
guys but they just asked me they're like
um so what do you do for work and I was
like
I'm I'm a YouTuber there were one same
here same here and then and then I don't
know if you had this as well then
figures vigorous typing like five
minutes yeah no I didn't have that oh
typing for like five minutes and I was
like
starting to get a little sweaty because
I'm like this is a long time literally
like I I want to say three to five
minutes total right me just standing
there where everyone else is getting
asked questions like that and I was like
did I answer wrong this YouTuber not on
the list they're not looking up on a
YouTube was and then she calls someone
else there but Whispers something and
I'm like what the [ __ ] did I do like why
I don't think I've done anything wrong
and then she's like
hey
um if you've won any awards or anything
I'm like
they don't really give them out for what
I do
YouTubers yeah
I was like I just was like I don't think
anything that would really apply yeah
and then she again types again for
another 35 minutes she's really nice
though but it was just very like
unnerving yeah everyone else was getting
asked questions and then yeah yes yes or
no then she goes right so can't give you
a Visa today and I was like what why
what I just answered two questions what
do you mean and then she goes but you
know it'll probably you know it'll it
might be approved and if it does it'll
just add two days to the process right
that'd be a piece of paper that in big
says refused and I'm like what and then
it says due to administrative processing
apparently the system was down right it
was terrifying because it said refused
and on the website it said refused as
well and it didn't say anything about
systems being down and for like a week
it's just said refused and I was like
it's just [ __ ] yourself we have to
cancel the tour like yeah like what like
what's what's out they've got on your
place
how would you get an American visa uh
well I have to get one for today yeah
there's boxing chess thing so gotta do
all this so I'm just scaring the hell
out of me so I emailed like the the
lawyer on a Friday Japan so like first
day for American yeah being like help
help what is this what is happening can
you please explain what's happening
thinking Oh They'll they'll reply
they're like never replied so the whole
weekend I was freaking out and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening is this bad
how bad is it is it fine it's probably
fine right I think I know it's fine but
it's kind of scary it says refused and
pig and then then like halfway through
our cycling thing it finally said um
processing and I was like all right good
we've got 10 of the loading bar done
yeah and then like near the end of the
cycling it finally said approved
yeah for the entire time during the
cycling thing people would be like can't
wait to see you in Nashville can't wait
to see you in Salt Lake City can't wait
to see you in New York and I'm thinking
if I get there what if the Visa gets
denied and I can't go what would have
happened if you couldn't go oh we would
have finally I would have had to cancel
the tour yeah let's put Connor I would
just hold an iPad
it's because
we've got a different visa for the tour
yeah yeah exactly see I had the complete
I had probably I've been to the American
Embassy a couple of times you know
because my Esther got denied one time
right yeah if Joey got it yeah and so I
had to apply for a business Visa the
first time around right and I kind of
had it like a similar situation when I
got the business Visa yeah
um whereas like I didn't get it
immediately but then I eventually got it
but then this time around with this tour
Visa I was just like the one was just
like so what are you doing I'm like I'm
a YouTuber it's just like oh you're the
first YouTuber I've ever interviewed oh
how much more yeah really yeah and I'm
like well there you go you just gotta
laugh I will say it is it's a terrifying
atmosphere because it's these through
Americans interviewing people yeah all
you hear is like what is your job yeah
your job what is it and then they say
something uh I I don't uh do and they're
like what is your job and it's
terrifying yeah yeah these people it's
like an interrogation yeah and there's
people can't really reply and in uh in
English yeah and it's just like These
Guys these people are trying their
hardest to speak in English it was
terrifying yeah yeah because these dudes
sound intimidating as hell because
they're just shouting and then oh this
one dude in front of me got rejected and
that was really sad and he was about to
like kick off and stuff obviously you
can't really kick off in the embassy but
that man like he's about to throw her
hands yeah it really worked up damn yeah
I mean like my interview was like pretty
easy actually I think it's like similar
to Joey where they asked me what I what
I do it loud so some people will like
get racist yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
terrifying yeah yeah
unfortunately like even if even if some
of the Japanese people could speak
English you know I'm sure like getting
shouted out was not helping their stress
level and the English language skills
but not like I got the same question and
they asked me what I did I said YouTuber
and then I I knew us I knew I was in for
like like a long explanation where they
were just like what is that yeah yeah
they were like how did you make money
so you asked me how I make money and I
go like oh you know I go I have like
advertising sponsorships and everything
like that I have different areas of
Revenue and then he goes who's who like
who puts advertisements on it and I'm
like oh my God
where ah this is going to be this is
like literally explaining to your dad
like how YouTube works and how you make
money and then I go to the I go through
like the [ __ ] five-step process of
explaining to your granddad how you make
money doing your job
and then and then after this five minute
long explanation here he goes did you do
anything before YouTube and I I go put I
put a cup
well I'll have you know I used to work
for the BBC and then as soon as I said
that he's like all right Visa approved
wow it's like probably the best one the
woman literally just said what do you do
and then she said what are you doing and
I was like I'm doing a tour and she's
like what do you do you going what are
you doing and I'm just like I'm doing a
tour with some friends and she's like
sounds fun all right your Visa's
approved oh it was like 30 seconds I
think I just gotten lucky on my team I
think you just got it yeah yeah because
I think normally what they do is they
pull up your application to look at it
yeah but I think they just had like my
piece of paper to go off of yeah what I
told them so they were just like yeah I
don't know what you're doing so I'll
hand it off to someone else in two days
maybe I had an easier time because I
applied for a business Visa before yeah
maybe maybe yeah I don't know why is it
that you know when applying for Visa
applying for like passports and [ __ ]
like that out of like all of the
documents that you need in your life
that you want the most information about
it's the hardest to get anything about
Visa or passport information yeah like
you send your Visa off for like if you
send your passport off for like a visa
application they're like I could be done
in like three weeks a month I don't know
you order a [ __ ] package of Amazon
you get like a [ __ ] hour by hour like
breakdown of awareness packages I got my
passport delivered to me and I was
[ __ ] myself yeah thinking that the
passport would get like lost in the mail
oh yeah